hey guys Pete here this will be a better
call Saul season 5 episode 4 trailer
breakdown in preview AMC networks put
out a proper trailer for the 4th episode
and a sneak peek video so I thought I
would take a closer look at those I'm
not sure if this will be a regular thing
but I have some free time this week and
I'm definitely thinking about better
call Saul spoiler warning this video
will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened and better call Saul up
until this point and the original series
Breaking Bad as it is a prequel I will
also be speculating about the future of
the season based on information that's
out there in the world out there in the
media so if you don't like that kind of
stuff this video won't be for you I will
break down the episode 4 trailer scene
by scene and discuss what all of it
might mean for the rest of the season
and then I'll discuss some interesting
things and a few questions that people
have been asking about the last episode
episode 4 is titled namaste and the
episode description reads as Jimmy
doubles down on Saul Goodman a deeply
conflicted Kim brings him an interesting
proposition
Gus makes a sacrifice to play the long
game Mike attempts to smooth things over
with his family the trailer opens with
the shot of Jimmy adjusting his ring
this is the ring that he got from Marco
his good friend back from Cicero that he
got after his death in the finale of
season 1 he's worn it throughout the
series as Jimmy and Saul we see it
throughout Breaking Bad as well but not
in the Jean timeline where he's trying
not to be identified the first time we
saw him do this adjust the ring was in
the finale of season 1 where he decides
not to go inside the courthouse to meet
with Davis and main right at the very
end the trajectory of that decision sort
of changed that season to develop from
what I understand but the ring is still
a reminder of his connection to slippin
Jimmy and his trying to be a respectable
lawyer which we saw him do as Chuck was
still alive through seasons 2 & 3
I think opening the trailer what's it
here is a fun callback and I imagine
that he's contemplating doing something
he knows he won't be able to take back
he's got something that he's thinking
about he knows that he's going to do it
but just needs that moment to reflect on
the fact
things are gonna be different after he
does based on the little bit that we see
in this trailer my best guess is that
this takes place before he enters the
courtroom which we'll get to later for
me the most interesting thing in this
trailer is this next scene a powered and
Jimmy having lunch in their conversation
Howard says tell me about Saul Goodman
what's he about this is interesting
because Howard seems to have a genuine
interest in this new persona and that
makes me wonder if HHM might have a use
for a lawyer like this of course the
Sandpiper case should still be ongoing
and that connects Jimmy and Howard but
this scene hints to me that there may be
more going on and I'm very interested to
see how Howard's story plays out since
we know he's not really around in the
Breaking Bad timeline after that we have
a shot of Hank
he has binoculars he's probably scouting
the deaddrop location that krazy-8 gave
him in the last episode for what it's
worth showrunner Peter gold made it
clear in the show's insider podcast that
episode four is the last one where Hank
will appear in this season here we see
him scouting and later we get a similar
shot of him where he's pointing a gun at
something and we can see Gomi in the
background in the passenger seat later
there's an overhead shot of a police
vehicle driving into a drainage pipe and
so it looks like we'll be getting to see
the DEA in action whatever happens here
my hope is that we get a nice conclusion
to their involvement that leaves the
door open to bringing back Hank and Gomi
again if it makes sense for the story a
lot of that will have to do with how
they handle the time jumps necessary to
get us to the breaking bad time line
we've still got four years between where
we are now and when the events of
Breaking Bad season 1 occur which leaves
things wide open in that regard we see
Jimmy in different points of this
trailer we see him in a police
department conference slash
interrogation room based on the bail has
been denied sneak peek video they put
out there he's probably talking to the
50% off guys here we hear him say you
torps even know who I am
later we hear him say I'm the real deal
so he's trying to sell himself for some
reason and while they don't give much
away in that sneak peek with the
80% off guys I think the big takeaway
from this is this was Jimmy's plan he
was planning on working with people like
this low-level criminals who are
constantly getting in trouble and that
he can make some money off of and what I
think is interesting in the whole
situation is is he was planning on this
but we saw what he got in the last
episode when he gets pulled in by nacho
and blingy to go see Lalo he's gonna be
dealing with people that he's
uncomfortable with it's not really what
he had in mind but that's where this
kind of work leads him we see him in the
courtroom which I mentioned earlier we
see a judge there and she says Oh mr.
Goodman so I feel like he's gonna do
something memorable in that situation
I'm not sure if those are the 50% off
clients it could be it could be anybody
he's got a lot of clients we know that
but I have a feeling that this is gonna
be one of the more memorable sequences
of this episode there is another random
shot of Jimmy he's pulling on a baseball
cap in a vehicle at night I'm not sure
what car he's in it could be Kim's but
it's definitely not his esteem we can
tell that it's a nicer car this could be
just about anything he may be having to
be there to report to nacho or what
happened or something like that I don't
think he's involved in any meaningful
way we get a little bit of Gus in this
we see him at a fryer pulling up the
baskets there's Lois polios employee
next to him who I don't think is Lyle
everybody remembers Lyle from previous
seasons I think it's a different
employee that later we see him breaking
a burner phone in his office where he
looks angry so that's what probably in
relation to what Lalo is doing but we
can't really make much out of what we
see in this trailer there's another shot
of Jimmy leaving the conference room at
the police station he says I'm coming
out and the guard comes to let him out
the door and then the episode 4 trailer
closes with the shot of Hank and Gomi
approaching the deaddrop with guns drawn
and flashlights in their hands the one
thing I think about in relation to their
story is they said their deal with
Domingo krazy-8 would be contingent on
making an arrest or arrest as Hank put
it so I'm wondering who will get caught
up in this it feels pretty
well-established that Gus doesn't really
care about the money as much as he cares
about dealing with Lalo so it'll be
interesting to see how this whole
situation plays out what we
don't see in this trailer is nacho or
Lalo we don't see much of them at all
since we're focusing on Hank and Gomi
going after the money we may not see
much of the Salamanca's in this episode
there will be fallout after the fact Oso
it'll be interesting to see how things
play out there we also don't see a lot
of Kim in this trailer but I'm very
curious to see what this interesting
proposition she has for Jimmy is the one
that they mentioned in the episode
description the two quick shots of her
that we do see don't give much away as
to what she'll be doing in this episode
which means we're gonna have to wait and
see we see her outside of the door I
think that's the courtroom again she has
like a serious look on her face she's
probably watching Jimmy do whatever he's
doing inside the courtroom and we see a
shot of her in bed and they're just
sleeping we don't really see anything
there they look normal
for the most part I'm really hoping to
get more with mr. Acker because I really
like the couple of exchanges we had with
them in Episode three but I'm guessing
that wouldn't happen until later in the
season if it happens at all as mentioned
I'm really excited to see how the Howard
part of the story plays out just like
nacho and Kim his story is a little bit
more exciting because we don't know
where he goes how he ends up not being
around anymore by the time of Breaking
Bad I really think that it's probably
not Sandpiper related why he has this
current interest in Jimmy he did mention
that HHM was doing well which was a
surprise and he was really in a bad
state whenever we saw him in season 4 so
this will be fun to figure out what's
going on in his orbit I mentioned mr.
Acker and a lot of people brought up the
question of wondering if Kim was
actually lying to him about her past I
thought the same thing in the moment but
then you know when you think about it it
does track we know that she is self-made
so that does track that she has this
kind of background that she doesn't like
to talk about because it wasn't a good
childhood I went back and forth a bit
but if you do watch the behind the
scenes video that they put out on the
AMC YouTube channel
the writers talk about it as if it is
true they don't say that outright and
you can make your own decision but it to
me it sounds like they're looking for
how they're going to fill us in on where
Kim does come from what her history is
and that's how they refer to that scene
they don't really touch on the idea that
maybe she was making it up or
embellishing it so we'll have to wait
and see but I'm leaning way more towards
her being honest there Rhea seehorn says
that she was depicting Kim doing this
like spilling her guts where she hadn't
planned to do that when she walked up to
the door so I think it's really unlikely
that she might have been embellishing
the story and Mike's part of the story
they also talked about how he is
basically punishing himself and I
mentioned that in my last episode IDEO
you know he feels like he's responsible
for letting things getting out of
control
to where he had to kill Werner and that
bothers him and that's understandable we
know that his motivation later in the
Breaking Bad timeline is to get his
money to take care of Stacy and Kayleigh
so it's looking like most of his story
is just gonna be about how he deals with
this and how he gets to where he's at
with them in that timeline so it's not
that the Mike story isn't interesting to
me of course he's a favorite character
he's a great character Jonathan banks is
a great actor who plays him it's just
sort of compared with everything else
that's going on his story is a little
less interesting to me because we know
how it ends up but that's always the
difficulty with a prequel and better
call Saul has surprised me in ways that
I would have never imagined when I first
heard about it in that dynamic you know
they made a prequel way more interesting
than I would have thought possible so
we'll see where Mike's story goes we'll
see how we get there I'm gonna end the
video now let me know in the comments
what you think did I miss anything is
there anything that you're thinking
about that you want to see happen and
give me some ideas for other bonus
videos if you have them please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I'll see you again
next week after the next episode drops
and I will talk to you soon